the best thing i did was probably this
is like a
breaking news and not now because i
always forget to like air my cloud off
right this because i'm like oh my god
i've been sitting on an exclusive year
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone do we just become best
friends
[Music]
howdy own waxers
welcome back to another episode
of the own wax podcast with the fans all
right we gotta stop this video i feel
like since leaving that concert the
other night oh turn off your
notifications i feel like leaving that
concert i'm still in this whole do you
hear my voice yeah you sound a little
hoarse
actually it's kind of ironic but no i
think because i was screaming so loud
for so many hours straight yeah that my
voice is shot sophie and i went to a
kenny chesney concert uh this past
weekend and
you know
i highly recommend um not going to a
concert when you don't know one person's
song that's performing like we didn't
know one song yeah it's we went not for
kenny chesney and i'm sorry for anyone
that's a big fan of him i know he's like
something that we've grown up with
apparently for country music but for me
i didn't care about him i cared about
two other artists and so sistine that
was dan and shea and old dominion yeah
they were fantastic they were the
opening but i had a lot of realizations
honestly like the group was fantastic
great vibes all around had a hot dog
lots of drinks i probably what like
seven cookies yeah i was going crazy i
split them with you yeah i was going
crazy but it was it was a great time
but i've realized that
after about three hours i'm good she
comes up to me at the concert and goes
you know i just realized in the middle
of the concert i go what she goes i
don't like concerts i don't i just i i
really don't like
i tried so hard to be like a festival
girly a concert goer because i like
listening to music but then when i'm
there in person and you're on your feet
all day
i'm just like you know what it is though
this is what i truly believe i think if
it was well throw out an example of
someone we probably know their music
really well is taylor swift let's say we
know probably 90 of her songs and like i
could say the lyrics you would love that
because every single song you haven't
seen into it but there was those lulls
because there were some songs and all of
the artists that we weren't of like
familiar with and so we wouldn't really
move so you're standing there and you
kind of get really really tired because
you were partying screaming for two
songs
and then you stopped for like 30 minutes
and you're like i kind of need to
lay down here i know but it makes you
think like do you like
concerts or do you just enjoy listening
to that person's music in the comfort of
your car i like concerts if i know the
artist and because i love dance i was
sweating and i was so embarrassed i
literally had to go to the bathroom and
like pat my shirt there was one under
the drive there was one point where
sophie and i have this thing where we
don't have to talk we can just look at
each other and we'll know exactly what
the other person is thinking and i
looked at her and then she gave me one
of these looks like
so i go let's go to the bathroom we go
right to the bathroom she like sits on
the floor like some heathen and like
takes her shoes off and just goes
mike gotta let the dogs breathe
they're pretty [ __ ] i'm not hiding my
feet right now no that was it was pretty
rough my feet are feeling it today yeah
feeling it but i once i'll tell you the
one thing i don't like about concerts is
the creepy men that stare
from that one guy you were talking to
every passer buyer no there was one
remember there was the one that was just
one guy creepily staring but you know
what it is i commented about yeah but
sometimes i'm i'm gonna give this guy
i'm gonna throw him a bone sometimes
when you get a guy who is creepily
staring in his mind he's just staring
like he doesn't know he's looking creepy
and then we're looking back at him
giving a look like why are you staring
at me you creep but in his mind he's
probably thinking wow she's checking me
out too this is happening something's
vibing like i think there's a lot of
miscommunication there right yeah that's
fair that's fair because he doesn't know
he's a creep yeah because i have a
staring problem too yeah so he was
probably like you're giving me eyes yeah
that's fair it does just annoy me so i
kept like thinking maybe if i intimidate
him with my stare
he'd look away but that was not very
oh wow she's undressing me with her eyes
yeah wow and then actually he did take
his shirt off so i was like all right
this is did he really yeah
so he probably was just assuming that
which sucks next time i know i'll just
block it off yeah don't look you know
what your problem is sophia every time
i'm like hey sophia look to your left
but just don't look right yet and i'll
wait till this person turns away and
she'll go who what look
at him every time well it's like saying
it's like you're dangling something
behind me how do i not love yeah but you
don't listen to instruction
there's a reason why i said don't look
i'm just assuming the person when you're
looking over wasn't looking over when
you were looking over and so i would do
it i know i actually did a problem i
remember my mom growing up even tell me
like because i like to study people and
like i like to see what people are doing
and then my mom would come up to when i
was younger and say why are you staring
at them well you honestly assumed that
every person walking by us was a
kidnapper
so you always were in like oh i did
things hyper alert yeah yeah my anxiety
was like really bad as young i always
thought everyone was out to get me yeah
or you actually was more them i was
really worried about you guys getting
hurt
oh yeah i was like a hawk or i used to
freak out if you were away for like 10
minutes like you didn't jump in the car
i remember you used to wait up when mom
and dad would go to a dinner or
something um we'd all go to bed but
you'd sit on the stairs waiting for them
to get home because you wouldn't believe
that they wouldn't get a car accident or
something on the way home god i know it
was rough i had to practice sitting in
my room and like reminding myself that
everything was going to be okay over and
over and over but it's interesting as
you get older it comes out in different
ways yeah like you fixate on different
things oh yeah yeah now it's like fully
centered on me
but that's okay everyone needs to be a
little selfish worrying about myself all
the time you actually did sort of a
selfish self-help
thing yesterday i know i did a sound
bath so steam gives me a lot of crap
about it because she thinks it's too
whatever i think it's a hoax to get
people's money
i think it's not a hoax i think it's
good for people that are stressed and
need to
decompress let me ask you this what
qualifies a person
to
hit a bowl
for 50 minutes
qualifies like why does this person
get paid this money to literally hit a
bowl when you could do the same thing in
your kitchen because it's nice when you
don't have to control it and they have a
bunch of different instruments it's not
just bowls there's maybe five in front
of you but then they also have something
that sounds like a waterfall they have
something that sounds like
like uh what's like a white noise like
something that completely gets you out
of your head so you're sitting there for
50 minutes just listening to these
noises and honestly
i think sometimes even if somebody's
don't work which i thought it worked i
fell asleep like a baby last night and i
really like i've been in my head a lot
um and it really got me out of my head
for at least 45 minutes i think just
like not thinking being alone with no
phone which is so hard to do with when
you're in your apartment or your house
like it is easy to get on your computer
watch tv even read a book like takes
thought mm-hmm i think that's why people
go just to not think for literally
you're gonna make this a regular thing i
think so i don't know if you can feel me
but i'm in my feels like things are
unlocked anyone can hear or listen yeah
just getting your feels right yeah we're
not going to talk about it but when can
we
i'm not ready yet because i think if i
start talking about it now i'll probably
start crying
so we're not going to talk about it but
it was nice to like finally not have
that
like yeah moment where i'm thinking
about
this person that situation whatever yeah
you know we can try this maybe i'll set
up a little
sound bath in my apartment you know i'll
have a pot i'll have a wine glass
different sounds different vibrations
let's see if it gives you the same
effect
wow i'm actually shocked that even
offers that i just feel like it's a
waste of money okay well i'm not going
to you anymore it works i'm going to
charge you um okay well with labor
speaking of doing things alone my
girlfriend maya texted me shout out maya
that she was sitting um after work in a
bar alone
and she was saying she was like how do
you because i think she remembered
things i've talked to on the show going
like how do i stay confident because i
don't have a book i don't have any
distraction and i told her i was like
that's so normal to do i feel like it is
pretty intimidating to go somewhere
alone but i'm glad she did and i feel
like more people need to do it
you know
it's a
form of like security i think like if
you're okay and comfortable enough to
sit with yourself and not really care
about what other people are
thinking about because quite honestly if
you walk into a bar restaurant and you
see someone sitting alone do you ever
think like why is that person never
never but we sometimes i don't know why
our brains automatically go to what's
everyone thinking when they look at me
i'm alone i'm a loser i got stood up
like no one cares no one cares and
that's what i was saying to her i said
you are not the only person to go to a
bar
after
work no it's not even that's it's just
like saying like you're the first person
we care so much about what other people
think when again it goes back to
jennifer saying you're not special
you're special just to your friends and
the people in your life but the general
public doesn't care what you're doing
they don't care if you're eating a pasta
alone at a bar yeah that's why i wanted
to bring that up just to remind people
in case you know i feel like we need a
reminder knowing like you don't need to
be i personally love getting better very
much that's what i'm saying like you
don't know i love it i did it last night
honestly eating and not having to talk
to someone across from you is so nice it
is really nice it's so nice well i think
if you spend a lot of your time with
someone whether you're in a relationship
or you're with friends you have
roommates
you don't you don't have that time alone
yeah so it's really really nice i want
to start
practicing because even though i am
alone i'll bring my headphones i'll go
and tick talk or watch youtube while i'm
eating dinner i'm gonna i really want to
try like no phones totally disconnect i
mean that might look a little creepy i'm
just like staring at you
sex like one person say hey i'm not
bringing my phone to dinner tonight i'll
be gone for an hour just warning you if
you need me i'll be here like oh no i'm
not doing that well i had to text you
about the soundbot thing because i was
like i'm not gonna be on my home phone
for an hour so in case anything happens
like not to me but like in general
you won't be able to reach me so
i think it's good to give a warning in
case
yeah well to me like you and i talk to
each other 24 7. yeah i'm not saying you
need to text like your parents like like
like pray for me make if i make it or
not but more in case like you're
constantly with someone maybe i agree no
um
i want to talk about
what happened to your friend the other
day with her car oh yeah oh that is
we're going on this creepy train right
now that is so scary yeah she was and
this is the craziest part is this all
happened in a gated community so it's
supposedly supposed to be safe um she
was in her car and so i think something
with her car needed to be fixed
um and so she took it from that gated
community where a house to the
i think the um what would you call it
the uh car service yeah and they found a
uh tracker
in our car or like maybe an air tag but
one of those tracker things and you she
was like i didn't even get a
notification on her my phone do you know
what i'm saying like that's how usually
you find this air trap and you never
know how it got in there it could be the
valet it could be someone washing your
car it could be no she said she got it i
think when she was in that gated
community i don't know why she said she
knew that can you imagine like you don't
know how long you've had this tracker in
your car you don't know who's been
following you watching you're coming out
of the grocery store you have no i think
the people are watching you they're not
only like you're going to your
boyfriend's place you're going to your
parents place you're going to your
friends now you know where all your your
like regular route is that's that's the
freakiest thing scary
being a woman is really scary it is
really scary i mean
i walk around pepper spray i jump into
my car actually
pepper spray no i'll like open the door
and then i hop into the car with two
feet because i'm convinced that
someone's going to like slash my uh
accused i swear to god i did that the
other day
well i don't remember the last time i
sat in my driver's seat and didn't check
the back seat before driving because i
always think someone just like crouched
down and all the time i know and i'm
like oh i guarantee you in this like
situation i'd be able to find myself no
when you're like in front of a situation
where maybe someone's been stalking
i sh i mean i've known when i'm
paralyzed or shocked by something i
don't move i'm like yeah you know you
think you're or how about this do you
ever get into a bathroom stall
in public and just
think that there's like a little camera
or something watching i always do no i
don't know why i don't think that or i'm
still superstitious like i think
someone's watching me on my computer all
the time that yes yes i always think so
which is not great but um yeah i always
think so i used to have a tag on my
computer this is why i turned off my
icloud because i'm just convinced the
cloud is
um the illuminati and they're stealing
all of our information you guys are
thinking oh it's safe i want to save my
text messages from 2013. why
why well it's more for like syncing your
contacts in your photos i love sometimes
when how many people let me ask you this
how many people in your contact list do
you actually contact
10 oh no not a lot why do we have
248 others well
i have i think i have more because i
think i'm saying i know i actually want
to soon
get a whole new phone and number
i think way too many people she's
cleansing well no i feel like i've had
it for so long i need to change it i
agree you know yeah and then you text
the people you actually text and someone
needs to get a hold of you they'll
figure it out yeah i agree like but the
point of this conversation is girlies
put some mace on your keychain yeah that
is something my dad has always done for
us since we were obviously at the
beginning of high school he not only
bought mace for sophia and i and
scarlett to put in our keys he bought
like 15 others just to give to our
girlfriends yeah and all of them still
have it today yeah they could save your
life it really can just have something
just so you have a peace of mind that in
worst case scenario you don't have to
like put a key between your thumbs yeah
and fingers and go
uh you know i also invest in claws yeah
claws go for the eyeballs you guys think
these are a lot and you guys are like oh
i can't text and i can't type i look
like a witch i'm telling you right i
can't pick up pennies so what go for the
hosts
go for that
you stick it in there
you don't need mace you just blot them
with your beautifully manicured thumbs
t
we have a really fun controversial
tabloid king
coming on our show today and this this
intro was a little down and debbie so it
will not match the energy to what we
just spoke about but we do have spencer
pratt
from the hills coming on on wax today
and we have so many questions for him so
many suspicions stay tuned
[Music]
gaps in the diet should not be ignored
over 97 of women aged 19 to 50 are not
getting enough vitamin d from their diet
and 95 are not getting their recommended
daily intake of key omega-3s rituals
essential for women 18 plus multivitamin
was formulated with research to help
fill nutrient gaps in the diets of women
ages 18 plus it is formulated with
nutrients to help support brain health
bone health
and provide antioxidant support but
ritual did not stop there they invested
in gold standard university-led clinical
trials to prove the impact of essential
for women 18 plus multivitamin the
results
essential for women 18 plus was shown to
increase vitamin d levels by 43
and omega-3 dha levels by 41
in 12 weeks so if you don't believe us
it was posted the clinical study in this
leading scientific journal frontiers in
nutrition a published clinical study is
a big deal in a series commitment to the
first of its kind standard in the
industry ritual is committed to
third-party testing from usp and the
non-gmo project traceable and vegan
friendly ingredients and always clear
communication so in the no shady stuff
sophie and i can definitely agree on
this we love taking rituals essential
for women 18 plus multivitamin because
it really makes me feel like i'm on top
of my health and i'm really taking care
of myself multivitamin is my favorite so
i completely agree i absolutely love the
fact that my stomach doesn't hurt like a
lot of those do and i love the actual
nutrients supporting the antioxidants
help that i've been looking for okay
here we go you guys right now ritual is
offering our listeners 10 off your first
three months visit ritual.com
unwaxed and turn healthy habits into a
ritual that is ten percent off at
ritual.com unwaxed go get it yeah go get
it
[Music]
we're gonna give this man a the intro he
deserves oh this here we go he walked so
other reality tv stars could run
becoming a household name from his hit
from his time on the hit show the hills
he has now created his own line of
crystals as a father of two and a social
media connoisseur this is pratt daddy
aka
spencer pratt studio audience
okay full disclosure not just uh like
kind of jump on you so when you said he
lived over there in the palace we saw
you a lot last week where um we saw you
at dinner we were at um what's that
italian is it angelini it's angelini's
yeah yeah we started walking around
is this so creepy or just such a
coincidence that we're about to have you
on our show
two days earlier you're in the palisades
like this is i know we were we're so
we were okay we were debating we're like
wait this is good content for me i know
the thing for me is was like i don't
want to interrupt their date night if
they're having a date night and you know
you don't want to introduce definitely
always
we had this lit drunk lady last night
donald trump sit down at our booth and
no it's like and i'm cool for like the
first like ten minutes yeah yeah and
then you're like cut it off like whoa
like we just like booked dinner with you
ladies yeah it was very nice and i feel
like people forget social cues well once
you're drunk it's like and it's not even
worth having a conversation with a drunk
person i've learned that not at all
being a drunk in the past
so like time is not even like okay and
finally our son gunner's four enough
it's like yeah she literally was like is
she going to leave soon i was like oh i
love kids they're just so honest
i was like
no yes
but yeah i feel like if the kid says so
you got to get out of here i don't think
you could you would have done 10 minutes
oh yeah well we would have probably said
hi but next time we'll if we see you
because they're always around there
we read up that you've been to usc
for 10 years yeah wait for 10 years well
i started in uh 2003 and then i
graduated in 2013. oh got it it was a
process okay i graduated from there so
that's safe right on i know
i hate to hate on it but i feel like
it's so
different now i feel like it's like very
different now ucla now it is it's i feel
like the i feel like when i got in there
and she went with me i think we were
kind of the last year that it was
probably the more traditional usc and
now it's so different it might have been
so fun when you went oh were you in frat
life or anything like that so
i tried to like so i was a spring admit
okay and and my best friend the time was
brody and he was and he'd already come
back he's a year ahead of me so he had
already dropped out or left that boulder
so
we were just partying on the road like
waiting for me to like start college and
we were always trying to get into the
parties and they were just like so hard
about it
not playing around why is the frat party
the most secure part oh it means you
have to be a brother oh they're they're
not playing and so
uh eventually we figured out like we got
a like
almost like an enforcer like our own
like bodyguard there was a couple of
times where we got into some beta
parties where
i think people weren't happy about how
it happened but we got it yeah this
backfired on me though because once i
got into college i realized oh you're
not going to like so i tried to then um
rush like veda no like i already had
like incidents with bro right
so long story short i go through the
most insane
hazing the whole thing right when i like
finally get in and they're extra after
me because yeah the sprint of the fall
yeah i'm trying to hack right right
right and they get thrown off the road
and so it becomes a secret society and i
was like i just hate like no like i did
this to like have that party in the
house to be able to hire people
that happened a lot with a lot of my guy
friends because one of the frats was
kicked off during um our year and
they're just like we came to like a lot
of guys want to i mean and girls like a
lot of it's the social scene at usc it's
really fun i mean everything else is
great but it's like that one year you
get in and all of a sudden like you lose
your house you lose all the rights and
then no one wants to go like a series it
was like a bunch of bar mitzvahs and i
like i love barbatos and i've been to a
lot but it was like that was like no
we're gonna have and you're still paying
all this money to go like off campus and
like get in a bus yeah it really does
i can't even imagine you allowing anyone
to even haze you like i think you're
just home well i mean we i got into some
this is when nobody knew jujitsu like
now everyone like knows right marshall
everyone's a tough guy now but like in
the palisades like hicks and gracie when
i was growing up was here so i grew up
doing jiu jitsu with all my friends so
right i was the only one that knew
jujitsu when i got to college so i was
in some serious oh gosh
scraps with the like older guys trying
to haze like it was on so i mean
i definitely held my own and it was like
wait they probably were expecting the
movie yeah they didn't know because i
was wearing all this chrome hearts and
like bill wall jewelry and like these
guys were all from like newport yeah
like one or two takeoffs i was like
taking off jewelry before it was like
going down
like hold on let me get my four
necklaces and my wallet chain off
you know
you had to take it you know so
one of the the hazing things was in one
of these guys ranches in the mountains
of ojai
and they're hazing everywhere and you
know everyone had to come with money and
these guys did what they did to like
stay up all night to haze and you had
you were pretty much financing this
lunatic psycho pass from the orange
county and i was the only one like
pretty much not from like newport or
whatever so totally you know i was like
la guy yeah they already like they
already hated the jump
he crashes our parties
every and more jewelry and orchards it's
way not cool for them and so they like
thought they were testing me and the guy
who owned the house was standing like
smoking a cigarette and they're like go
push them in the pool and they thought
i'd be like i can't do that you know
because it's the middle of night there's
like a layer of like ice the winner up
in the mountains
and they thought i'd be like i can't do
that and i just like boom
push them and all of a sudden they're
like in shock that i push the owner of
the house like this 50-year senior in
the world stop so they all start chasing
me and you know it's like just the
middle of the night like and these are
you know you hear about like people
getting killed being hazed like you know
like
people are nuts oh yeah when they you
have free reigns so i climb like a tree
in like the orange groves of this ojai
and i'm like just eating oranges and
like like hahaha
there's so many oranges up here
so healthy yeah i was like this is so on
my diet and
finally they're like we're gonna [ __ ] of
all your guys and it's like i do like
some of these guys and they're all i was
like i don't want my people i do like
so you do build that and i was like what
are they gonna do to me totally so
they're like unless if you don't want to
get beat up or whatever you need to jump
in the pool and and so i just like
cannonballed off the diving board and
not knowing this is like hypothermia so
like i turn like blue
like i'm by like a fire like shaking it
was but i mean it was all worth not
having a frat but yeah it's a great
story today so then i go back because
heidi makes me go back to like you
should finish college oh yeah how many
years were you there for then so right i
was only there for a minute and then i
got on the hills and i was like trying
to do tv and i was like getting fda i
was like it's hard to man yeah this is
not happening with like
no usc is better about it now because
there's a lot of people that are in the
industry but before i guarantee they
didn't oh this i would try to tell the
teacher would be like
f don't worry about that oh i don't like
the show so when i went back i like
knocked on beta's door and i'm like i'm
going to van wilder this and i'll be
like the new like oh you went over sorry
knock on the door they're like i'm like
yeah i was uh you know they're like
what's your um like number i'm like i
don't remember my number like whatever
like you know like you're yeah you did
you stick your i don't know i don't know
what they called it i was like i don't
know i was in this in like oh we don't
recognize that chapter oh that was pre
i'm like no i you know i don't recognize
you you little
you're like what are you doing and i'm
like so what do i have to do to like
give them like well first what's your
gpa i'm like are you kidding me and like
we average a four point i'm like oh my
gosh
right now shut this door the best thing
i did was probably so this is like a
breaking news and not now because i
always forget to like air my cloud off
right this because i'm like oh my god
i've been sitting on an exclusive year
right so at first i tried living at the
medici right when it opened oh really
what it is now yeah and it's just like
it's called that right no i think only
just drug dealers live there i've seen
like memes and it's like if you sell
dreams
i don't know so i went there for a
minute i was like because it just opened
and it was like the height like the
first yeah
so i was like i'm going to get a loft
so right on skid row in the old bank
district
uh i got the penthouse which was out of
like a movie scene i didn't understand
what skid row was and when you go
look to like get something you go like
this is pre now it's all downtown but
yeah
like the zombies would come out at night
but at daytime when i went and looked i
had no idea i was like this is crazy
right right so i get like this you know
20-foot ceiling penthouse out of a movie
but it was so expensive that i had to
get like my buddy another guy named
spencer yeah to like split it and then
this girl i kind of knew
but the guy it was a two connection
penthouses and connecting penthouse to
ours was ryan gosling ryan gosling had
just broken up with sandra bullock no
there was no internet so i had no idea
like no he was just like the skinny
canadian yeah right right wanted to
party with us stuff
and i'm gonna save all my like great
ryan gosling
he pays me to like
to like not talk about that wait so you
partied with a broken-hearted ryan
gosling oh he didn't break his that guy
still he was he was kicking that he's
fine look
he didn't look like the standard had
just opened in downtown so we would go
to like the standard so like i see world
it's like good that i was so far totally
famous because i think i would have been
in a lot of trouble in a frat no i was i
lived on the road for a year and that
was pretty wild i mean i did the whole
like four years intensive like sorority
life college life and it was fun but
it's definitely like a beast in its own
i'm really curious so you went to
college
started doing the hills went back to
college
what was it like coming back to school
and then everyone seeing this massively
popular show that you were on so this is
all like pre like that's the thing with
the fame we have like there's no
instagram there's no so
yeah unless you're reading tabloids or
watching the show like which college
kids aren't and it was so i did it so
quick like i
probably was only there for like a
semester but it hadn't it didn't
effectively think um so it hadn't hit
like that
you know it would have been a whole
different world social media oh yeah
instagram and snapchat you probably
would have to do online
it just would have been different
yeah it would have been a totally
different photo i probably would have
stuck it out and like this is i'm so
famous i'm always curious when we
interview people on reality tv shows
when you sort of signed up for the hills
or maybe they reached out to you
whatever it was did you want to sort of
create this narrative for yourself
you're like oh i want to be the good guy
i want to be the villain or do they sort
of do that for you oh the hills didn't
want me on the hill so
like um when i was in college and brody
i was still hanging out
uh then we beefed out because i started
dating you know she wasn't an actual
prostitute but like a very somebody he
didn't want to be yeah yeah i shouldn't
have been around
oh yeah
and so he was like we were not that cool
at this moment but then i like i don't
know if i read it or i saw it but i yeah
i saw the osbournes and i heard they got
25 million dollars for like the next
that was the oh geez and i was like they
were getting five million each and i
mean i watched the show but it was there
was nothing happening you know like it
wasn't like that's chaotic it was just
like yeah the dogs are pooping
i'm like yo we need to do a reality show
about you because he had way more dogs
pooping everywhere in his house and he
had a step dad way more entertaining
than ozzy osbourne this guy david foster
yeah right right and he's like no no
pratt he's like so we go to dinner down
the street when pf changs was popping
yeah and and i talk him into it he's
like if you're here tomorrow morning so
i had had a camera that i had tried
filming this thing it didn't work out
right so i call my parents i'm like i'm
taking a leave of absence i'm going to
shoot a reality show they're like oh my
god this was lost his mind they're like
what is he doing because it's not a
thing oh no no it's such a negative
seriousness only the paris show
uh
totally
survivor like it was there what are you
even talking about it's only the
challenges that the ones are not as
judged harshly as like the ones where
it's about someone's real life so like
getting actually i'm shocked that you
were able to convince a family to like
do it well then it took like a summer
like they didn't believe me they were
just like this is brody's lunatic friend
filming everybody
and the footage i was getting of david
foster telling me like get the [ __ ] out
of him i swear yeah oh yeah yeah i won't
[ __ ] with your ads so
he's i get the [ __ ] out of my house and
like really like oh no stop [ __ ]
filming me and so i'm like yeah using
all this footage this is good
i was like this is amazing
and so it made the sizzle just so good
of him because it was so real right
right and that sold so we were on fox
for two nights two
weeks on sunday nights like big blah
blah blah called the princess malibu but
then
linda filed for divorce from david right
after it so i get the call like oh it's
cancelled so now i go back to usc
like oh my god it would have worked oh
if they stay together i'd be
i would be a multi-millionaire
it was never going anywhere
it was like i mean family friends it was
everything fox wanted right we had
in between simpsons and i wouldn't have
probably met heidi and my life would
have been so different but i definitely
would never have been hated and i
definitely would have been a millionaire
yeah and i don't know it would have been
different yeah just so many but like my
whole like one thousand percent was
working did you know like speaking of
heidi did you know that she was gonna be
the one the first time you met her
or did it was it was slow burn she said
she knew love at first i was younger
than her so it would have been hard for
miley yeah like love radar yeah that
night
i'm wearing goggles yeah like dancing so
then
i went back to college i was like oh my
god i need to get on tv again that was
the easiest best job in the whole world
and my my parents live in the palisades
so i was like home from school for like
you know just drove my mom and her best
friend watching a show yeah my mom's
best friend lucy was like you should
date this girl and i'm like what are you
guys watching and it was season one of
the hills and she was pointing out heidi
i'm like what is this show no i'm like
they're in hollywood doing a reality
show i'm like i never even heard this
because nobody had heard of this it was
it was gonna get canceled that's why
everyone's like oh
like you should be so thankful of blah
blah well they i came and saved the day
right i am the hero you need to have the
the villa i mean like always wait so
you're going to take a friend so i see a
name of the show i'm like who's doing
the show and one of the guys that just
worked for me on my fox show was the
producer so i call his cell phone i'm
like [ __ ] you didn't put brody
and i on this show and he's like spencer
no i just got the job it's like a set
cast from these girls
and he's like they already had they have
their boyfriends i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ] i will see you in the club four
okay
so it was on so i called brodie like we
need to get and he's dating
kristen cavallaro right right so
she was more popping than that whole
show that's why she didn't do it because
she was like doing acting yeah and so we
were kind of still getting the clout
from kristen
so i was trying to like hype brody on it
but we kind of like forgot about it
totally then we're out in the club i
have a bad timeline but which club were
you guys out this was privileged it's
not hide but it was just
[Music]
yeah
i know where it is preston heights and
sunset yeah yeah yeah and kristen and
brodie and i were out and i guess heidi
had knew kristen from like a little bit
of laguna beach and she was like set me
up with somebody who's like oh
censor so that night we got set up on
the dance floor and on the dance floor
you fell in love we went back to bro all
the way back to malibu yeah and had a
great night and then so we were kind of
like hooking up seeing each other but
then heidi told kristin that i was in
love with her which you know i was not
wait wait wait wait wait
that you were in love with her and so
chris that one night
like maybe a couple days did you call
her out yeah so i was like what do you
think i'm in love with that you're
tripping like
so then like we have how do you think
she said that
i mean
i she's trying to try christine could
have like also
like said something
like you know been exaggerating totally
yeah you know it could have been a
non-issue and christians you know pumped
it up a little bit yeah i was like why
aren't you treatment
and so chad is like oh really and so she
changed her number on me
and this is back when you
i mean she's going to change her whole
number because of that situation i mean
but that's a powerful that is a people
after because then we saw each other in
the club when this drama and she said
like i had like
like had these other girls but we were
in excuses yeah
and so i was like but
so is it when you guys started recording
the hills when you sort of came together
so then season two of the hills is just
starting filming and the thing with
heidi it happened in the summer right
and now brody's dating nicole richie
and we're out at chateau marmont
and randomly like audrina is there yeah
i don't know audrina but i like i don't
know the nicole richie's best friend
this girl sophia was the talent producer
of the hill so yeah so i think sophia's
maybe with us she's like oh audrina's
gonna come by i was like and i hear that
audrina and heidi aren't getting along
because heidi was backed up lc because
audrina was hanging out with jason
blah blah blah blah blah blah
deep who cares drama
and so i'm like junior we should roll up
to the club where heidi's working and
you know piss her off and make drama and
she's like okay
and why not so
that's they got that clip and then it
like it worked and it worked out
was it hard to maintain a relationship
with cameras on you guys all the time
i'm also trying to keep the drama up
right because isn't it wasn't where you
guys and together not the whole yeah
yeah yeah we always
knew my agenda which was like steal the
show and spin off so that's probably why
it works yeah like she let you do it and
i was transparent but once she would
drink sometimes she'd like forget like i
told her i'm bringing these like this
one playboy was popping like i was
bringing these playmates and like we're
going to make this drum we're going to
bring the play mystic club but once she
drank she was like i can't believe you
know yeah
you know
becomes real and like i don't even care
everything you're like i love you
it's really difficult for your
relationship at points when you guys
would try to manipulate the camera
manipulate the audience at the expense
of both of your emotions i would say
just a couple times you know i didn't
like i don't think she liked when i got
drunk and
editing like
is crazy because yeah like drunk talking
to a girl at a bar just no matter what
comes off his flirting but like one of
these scenes with this bartender that
was totally staged and you know i feel
like i love the movie coyote ugly and
she like was dressed like a girl that
would be doing a kylie like i'm like
people and it felt like a coyote
ugly bar and i was like do you like do
people do like the bartenders dance here
like i know in my heart you know like i
was not spitting game i was just asking
you guys
yeah drunk like they dance people dance
but it like comes out like oh you like
so
being stupid and drunk yeah and like
also trying to like make the scene
that's obviously to have you sitting at
a bar for six hours with the same
bartender that's oh yeah trying to make
is the new character and like they're
giving you non-stop your favorite
tequila like it ends up being it ends up
going sideways how much did the
producers manipulate situations like
that or manipulate even just you guys i
mean we were so down because like
we weren't the narrator so it's like any
bit they're gonna be like this is it or
you're not getting paid it's so
interesting though because most people
that do these types of shows today are
like i need a good edit i don't want
them to manipulate me or make me look
bad whereas you guys are all like we
want this to work we don't really care
and i think that's really like not a lot
of people have the balls to do that
today we also didn't know about like
blowback there was no social media like
comment sections hadn't dropped but also
that's
so different yeah and it was like
the money was so much more back then so
you know we're going oh no people don't
like us shopping best dinner
what's the problem and then i like call
my dad as a dentist like they're trying
to do this and make me look like this
and he's like spencer i go to work on a
saturday for like 80 teeth cleaning like
and they're paying you how much yeah
okay
later like they're buying sorry yeah so
i know that's actually so true you
forget like how like the real world real
world it's like i'm crying about oh my
god they're making me so hated like
they're like um i'm cleaning fish guts
yeah like first year it was nice that
you didn't get blow back ben but do you
feel like you're getting it now no now
it's like the best thank god for
snapchat so snapchat
when snap was popping when it first came
back like i was getting five million
views of snap so i was doing better than
the hills ever did wow when i like about
this like now 2016 2017 so it's like a
couple years when i was just getting
like
everybody that would come up to me
didn't even know i was on the hills
they're like i love you from snapchat so
oh wow i got to like re
like brand through that app mm-hmm you
know yeah so crazy and that's probably
having more control over it yeah and it
was just real it was just my life
whatever all day long and yeah this was
before people storied
like i i i will take full credit to be
the first human being to truman show
like their account you know okay so when
snap first came people would just take a
photo or send like a naked pic and then
right when you could do video i was like
oh i'm gonna make that my reality show
and i just filmed like my snap would be
two hours long oh so you were kind of
like the first like reality show
snapchat story i was the first person in
this story like no one yeah no one's
story like that i like people were like
oh my god you do so many videos and then
so ig story i also was the first person
to do like
right like i'm talking now
like all gunners friends moms at school
have longer stories than me you know
like oh yeah yeah i know everyone does
that but like i was a weirdo for like a
good year and a half like extra weird
instincts with that stuff well i was
like i got my own show like and i'm
looking at the views like and i started
from the ground up like five thousand
twenty thousand like i built you tried
obviously yes and i was like
hustled so that changed the like oh
spencer's hate it but when the reruns of
the hills hit mtv i'll have like five
lunatics like be out of a tweet mention
like oh my god i can't believe you did
that to heidi it's like yeah you're like
years later and it was like i didn't do
anything you're like have a kid now you
knew everything
yeah did you always want to be famous oh
yeah i don't know why like i wanted to
be like a movie star but like i really
so like calling me q and was like the
pop in summer school malibu at cross
creek yeah and like i have people that
will tell me at summer school like i
would show like us weeklies and be like
just get ready i will be on the cover
and be like what are you talking about
you meant it so like i just like
interesting i took two niche like why
did i like i went after like us weekly
fame like i should have been like yeah
like i should have said yeah i should
have reported or something like that it
was too detailed but you know i grew up
and went to crossroads so everyone like
all my friends parents were a-list movie
stars yeah director like i was like this
is the dopest life ever it was now it's
whack i think i'd rather be addison ray
than
than like a mainstream movie well it's
like the i think the value of a famous
acting like actor is not as yeah it's
like how many views can you get it
you can be an influencer
yeah
if she was a better actor i haven't seen
her movie she could
she could yeah but if she could jennifer
lawrence it they would let her in like
full trust when you were starting up
there weren't that many famous people
now yeah like oh everyone
it's like it's almost become so washed
down and now everyone is famous and
honestly i think there's going to be a
whole new shift in this where it's not
going to be a thing anymore of
influencers like it's going to be
so i was the first reality
person i to being a tabloid i was the
yucca meter in star magazine i cut it
out i framed it because i remember
reality reality tv people hadn't even
got like paris was already in for
pre-reality shows so she doesn't count
but like totally for being on a cast of
a reality show we were we broke into
yeah so at one time tom cruise hired my
publicist thinking that that was why i
was getting so much fame hired my
publicist to then fire him and gave him
like a non like this is a true story
shout out rick rhodes wow he literally
because tom cruise i was getting more
press than tom cruise no because facts
wow and he thought it was because my
publicist right right but it wasn't it
was how did you constantly stay relevant
in the town calling the tabloids and
working with the editors and like making
up stories and setting up like your
paparazzi photos what was the craziest
story anything every single there wasn't
a normal
every story that was ever made up was
there ever a story that you actually
really hated though
no i like was
oh
is that confidence or is that just you
no i knew i know how hard it is to get
in these magazines especially now
now like us weekly comes out like every
three weeks there's only there this thin
they like have like four photos in it so
it's like smarter right right right i
was gonna say because you're really
honing in on the whole fact of it's
worse if you're in the public eye you
have people complaining oh i wanna be
photographed paparazzi wait till the day
they don't photograph oh my god and i
felt that like i had a rap song i did
like jokingly but real because i was
trying to do
like i was like i'm gonna do the song
for i'm a celebrity get me out of the
show i didn't even see the jungle so
yeah tried to do the theme song but in
it and it was like a lion was like
spencer pratt uh
not famous whoa that's scary and it's
like then when i wasn't famous i was
like holy [ __ ] this is way scarier than
i even like jokingly because what people
don't get is like a-list movie stars
have to stay relevant yeah because
there's only so now more than ever
there's only nine movies coming out a
year and the real stars don't want to be
on all i do netflix but real stars don't
want to be on netflix
they'll take the check but they won like
tom cruise didn't even he fought with
paramount because they tried to put him
stream
after 45 days he's like i'm done with
you like i don't even want to stream for
six months so
like
the my
thirstiness is i learned from this the
goat right like superstar
it's and now with how saturated the
market is
like if you can get anything anything is
a win
people don't
get like nobody cares no about anybody
no like so everyone your best bet is to
like build your own following and like
care about that it's actually so true
who someone said this to us about you
can't ever again there's not going to be
there's not going to be icons there's
never going to be like there's such a
few people said this yeah dad is like
one of the few
an icon again
yeah he's like and i love that's why i
love famous people yeah because i love
you know the rambos i love
the you know cool even james bond fell
off he was my favorite person and i like
walked out of the last chainsaw i'm like
i don't even care about james bond
anymore like what has happened to like
like society and culture yeah i don't
even care about my favorite double 07
and it's like
i know because because we know too much
and that's the problem the whole point
of having icons was not knowing that
much about their lives like that's why
keanu reeves with winona right now
it's like almost a giant person with a
cell phone is a famous person oh that's
perfect point right there yeah so when
heidi and i were being fame wars and
setting up our paparazzi and getting
like cancelled before it's like it was
like canceled in the sense like oh
they're so thirsty and desperate cancel
getting canceled for being like
self-aware and promoting ourselves now
every single a-list celeb
films themselves and post stuff that if
heidi and i had done this in 2008 we
would have been like oh they're so so
crazy cringy like oh my god look at that
i'm bad if you're not doing it
you're not relatable or whatever i'm
like these [ __ ] do you think it
was a jealousy thing because of course
we were getting all their juice where
they
jen aniston wouldn't even talk to us
weekly before heidi had four cover like
heidi got half a million dollars to do
four covers where she talked us we bet
before heidi started doing like sit down
with us we nobody talked to us magazine
it was like
it was like trash mag next thing you
know weddings
giving you like the scoop and all that
was like these [ __ ] i know you
know and their agents heard how much
we're getting and it's like yeah so and
the only thing you can do today is
honestly just building a really strong
small following or you or a huge
following if you can but people that
actually want to follow you and
understand your life like you can't just
have like a massive amount of people
fall in love with you anymore it's not
like that what i realized selling the
crystals also is
you could have like people were like oh
my god you only have uh like a half a
million ig followers which by the way
i'm 100 shadow band and it's i really
have 40 million but no no so um but it's
like
selling a product you see like the same
people that want to support you yeah you
could have 10 people that like cover all
your bills because it's true they're
like they will love your products they
have a solid black card or whatever
however they keeping it's like you don't
need
five likes you don't need 190 million
people to have a successful small
business all right talk about your small
business when
and why did you want to start selling
crystals like what is the meaning of
crystals to you i love puzzles by the
way so
in the hills days you know so i
one thing i did learn like being so
hated at the time with the hills because
i was
scary hated like thankfully i didn't
i felt it you know like when you have
millions of people hating you it's a
real and you're like you know it like i
mean i was driving around stand up like
i i remember being right here on
26th street driving like past the
countrymart and like people just
flicking me out off like when i'm like
oh my god you're like it's working yeah
i was working
but the weirdest part is like i
literally the song i was listening to at
the time every day was the song mano
like hi hater bye hater so like i was
literally like hi hey like so i was too
deep i was like whoa this is crazy and
then full circle it just was too much
like managing like our lives so i look
to crystals as like i need like tap into
like a new energy all right you know
like i did god like i was going to
church because heidi's super you know
yeah so she's really she's like
preacher taking me to church every
i didn't know that so a
sunday and
like all were going out in the valley
one of those big churches and i didn't
understand like you only get saved once
but i kept on going at the end of church
they'd be like anybody that wants like
feels they have sin or whatever and i
would always like go up on stage in
front like 100 people and like heidi's
like you know you only do it once i'm
like it's been a crazy week honey like
so these little churches i was like i
got literally like devils
saved every sunday and it was like
everybody else did like once their lives
so i tried that and it was like you know
i wanted more energy and more right so i
started
how it started is there used to be a
crystal store across from base cities
and i was waiting for my godmother and i
saw this huge crystal and i went over
and i gave my credit card and i come
back and i was like yeah deliver that
this this is when we're balling so i
even like asked how much i was like it's
a rock right right like
i'm not buying a rolls royce so it's
like i'll take that his address deliver
it so at this time i had a business
manager and they call and they're like
uh you have fraud on your car don't
worry we stopped it i'm like what was it
like they said it was a crystal i'm like
no no i bought that and they're like
for 65 000 and ten thousand dollar
delivery charge i was like
what so i call back and he's like this
is from a volcano in peru and gave me
this whole great [ __ ] hype like you
know this is like yeah i still have it
um so
i mean it's three thousand pounds like
you can't like oh
that's the biggest crystal you've ever
seen you just saw a giant crystal like
that yeah i was like that's the dough
that's got power like i'm not gonna have
a small one so i am convinced in heidi
that this like attracted like it was
like a tractor beam that like wants more
crystals what type of crystal is that
the quartz
generator
and so we started buying so many
crystals this was pre-ig against pre
anything so we're getting so ripped off
like i should have just gone all the way
to like arizona yeah and like on it like
bottom during the gem show right it's
like right i also was bawling so hard
and didn't think i was like not gonna be
crazy rich so it's like right you don't
care about buying retail totally you
know you're not like trying to like so
it's hard a blessing and a curse because
i got so into crystals but it's also i'm
like still mad about all these crystals
because technically you can't put a
price on crystals because they're all
one of one yeah so like we're we vow
like you said about how much was that
worth to you at that time you know so
you start kind of like playing
games mine is yourself so that's why i
got on the crystals then heidi got
plastic surgery and like no vicodin no
perk nothing was working and i was like
playing nurse and this was like the
worst thing of our lives so i'm on
google like what [ __ ] and crystal will
help paint like a pain yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah looks like what did she get
that so i went into so much pain though
oh she got like here's what we learned
from plastic surgery and everybody in
the world should know this there's no
such thing as here's in the air quotes
minor surgical procedure so when a
plastic surgeon or a doctor anyone tells
you it's a minor surgery there's no such
thing as minor once you are getting cut
we've we've left right minor so
pre where you can look at i'm not going
to start name dropping the celebrities
and how they do it spread it out it's
just like this the big time plastic
surgeon that's showing heidi the secret
book of all the a-list actors that
aren't talking she's like oh my god
everyone's done it and then it writes
the price of like oh this will cost you
a million dollars but if you do a cover
i'll do this all for free all these are
minor minor minor most people spread all
this out probably over two years so
heidi just all at once so you know key
word this is minor
you just drawing a little blue lights
major yeah yeah and then it's so it went
so south so [ __ ] bad so it was like
getting dropped out of a plane so i'm
like searching crystals
and i read one sugilite so from this
place mine in africa so i go buy like a
fifteen thousand or chunk of sugilite
and she holds it and sleeps for the
first time all night so that's when i
turn full harry potter
lost the plot like went wow way too deep
into crystals where i'm like using wands
to like open portals to like enter into
georgios and like
you know like i can't like oh i was
going everywhere with crystal wand oh my
god
so i i'm uh an extremist i've decided so
i work on like balance right i guess you
can't say extremists i'm like what's the
ones you're wearing right now security i
am not an extremist i have extreme
tendencies with crystals
well you know what's interesting because
we grew up around crystals my dad has
what giant rocks this big all around
yeah
believes in it yeah he loves it as well
so we understand what you're saying you
have to have balance like your dad is
also like working out and like yeah
that's true you know like my mom gave
him balance though because if it wasn't
for her saying enough about heidi's
wearing a crystal crown with her wand
and we're like doing like you know like
they had done the reality show on the
real heidi instance here this time we
would have been the most famous people
in the galaxy
i know
no i mean we were not this crazy at this
point you know like this was like like
peak you know like we're
covering ourselves with meteorites when
we sleep no way
my s it's my son's favorite so i keep
wearing a lot of and and it's also my
most expensive size really you still
wear like drip and it's healing egg is
that so is that from yours yeah this is
proud to adopt so do you source of jesus
so my buddy lives in nigeria yeah that i
grew up with so he oh he sends them to
you he goes to the mine and like we
what's that so these are quality
crystals oh my aquamarine and tourmaline
are because i go to farmer's markets
i'll never hate on any like you know
because people always say that i'm like
why are these so much cheaper i'm like
because that's a farmer that's a
farmer's market crystal and then all my
non-aquamarine and tourmalines
are from a famous
couple that have been cutting and
carving crystals for 35 years so i
poached them and said hey when you want
to retire and not travel all the world
doing the gem shows yeah because like
they have been sourcing their crystals
for 30 years stuff that you can't even
buy now
you know they have just
all of it and he takes the raw material
cuts it polishes it so i said when
you're ready to like be just for me i'll
be exclusive to you so i only sell
this guy kurt moniks like hand
cut
like jewelry so that's why mine is so
expensive because it's not which you
know i love all crystals so like you
know if somebody gets it from china and
it looks cool great like
no it's nice to know it's sourced from
like a true place like somebody in
northern california that's spending a
day
hand cutting your price from like rough
but if you just want to get cheap rose
quartz from china the farmer's like i'm
not going to hate on that whatever maybe
it's like fashions you want to you're
buying a designer right right and you
mentioned your son gunner right yeah i
love that name by the way i feel like
you're very funny yeah
uh a new name do you not uh so you guys
haven't thought of the name yet heidi
has one locked in but it's still like
but you're still 50 if you have a banger
it could what name would you go for if
you could choose oh mine are two like
you know action movie like because he's
gunner i wanted blade like and she's
like you can't have gunner and like a
little crew like this isn't the
expandables
but no i mean it's just i like it it's a
little edgy
did you ever think you'd be a dad like
did you ever want to be a dad i mean i
always growing up imagine being a dad
but then once like
i got so hated and so much negativity
for a long time i was like i wouldn't
want to do that to my kid but then as i
grew up i realized that's so
like
narcissistic like self-centered where
like i would want my kid to upstage me
and where like my google wouldn't even
be
like you'd have to dig to find them
of
my kids right of course like
i'm irrelevant to their lives so it took
once i started looking in that way
versus like oh my god i would hate for
them to like grow up with like anything
i've done out there it's like yeah so
they're gonna be oh they're way more
successful than me based off of like the
game i can put on them but i do have to
say like you and heidi there were two
things that you guys have done recently
that i was like this is
incredible and it's keeping you
extremely relevant i saw
you storm off of the call her daddy
podcast and in my mind i was like i
don't know if this is real i don't know
if this is fake but it did incredible
press
and then good for alexander cooper was
fake and it was her plan i knew it yeah
she's so smart though it's genius she's
it falls like
you are scary smart and also heidi
eating raw animal organs yeah that was
all heidi she really was doing that wait
is she and i think it really helped her
get pregnant because she couldn't get
pregnant for 18 months and so she like
we had heard about doing like raw yeah
me and then she started doing it and
then she got pregnant it could be a
coincidence but like what type of raw
animal well like so if you're gonna eat
organs like don't go get them like at
your market and like oh you have to like
you have to get them from like a
grass-fed farm and like the farm ships
and the cooler and i mean it's just
testicles is like the hardest thing you
could do like you wouldn't even imagine
your testicles like you can't eight
testicles it's harder to get tests like
like bison tests like raw bison
testiculars are harder to get than a
birkin bag
yeah i was gonna say
what were your thoughts when like you
walk into the kitchen and this is the
scenario played up in my head you walk
into the kitchen you see heidi just
chomp down on the liver she's so nice i
tried and
what are you doing i tried to eat the um
is it bloody and everything oh my god
did she look like a vampire
i mean
it made me realize that like there's for
sure like some weird stuff going on on
earth
do you still kiss me after are you like
you gotta go i mean like blood wasn't
like
definitely i'm not like i also not a
huge like kisser has never been i think
she's like really into kissing that was
what you're not super affectionate i'm
affectionate but i just never understood
like kissing the way she did like she's
right yeah i think it's like she's like
out of those movie scenes i'm like
nobody does that she's like a hopeless
romantic yeah like she will i'm like
what are we doing like this is like too
much of my time you need that balance
though it's yeah i know you guys need a
show and i'm i'm here for your show yeah
so the producer of the hills
they're like we're you know we didn't
give up you know like so good we all
wanted the hills to keep going our cast
was the most hot garbage cast in the
world like our cast would rather be on
ig story than on mtv which is
interesting
because they want to control their image
image craft and you know have no way to
so part of me is so upset that we lost
it but the other part of me is like they
don't deserve to be on a television show
why don't you guys try it with mtv then
just like your family i mean you have
the whole cause yeah you know mtv
is an interesting place from what if you
watch you know like what they're going
they're kind of going after all their
nostalgic things so they gave us the
nostalgia like they gave it to like so
when i was popping on snapchat
in 2017 i went and met with mtv and they
offered heidi and our own show
my dumb ass was like let's bring the
hills back oh no like one of the biggest
mistakes of my life because i thought
i'm looking at you guys in new
beginnings or whatever that was what
they brought that was oh yeah yeah so
that was right yeah no no no they just
called it new beginnings they just added
brandon oh that's the only person yeah
yeah and brandon was that's the problem
like when they added brandon he was not
sober he was beating up his dad like
right it was mad action and then we get
like dead sober reinventing my image
brandon right very different
very different yeah that's a different
person for reality television right you
can't have people on reality television
trying to make images you have to be
yeah who you are
it depends on the reality show you're
trying to go for it yeah if it's like
celebrity rehab then that guy jason
waller and his wife would have been
great brandon would have been great like
if you're just going to like talk about
therapy
and sobriety yeah then that should be
the show but if it's like partying in
hollywood hills and that's what we were
famous for and going to clubs yeah yeah
like yeah we're older you have this down
to like a science like the way that you
just understand this well-oiled machine
of reality you should create a
production company a production company
like literally give a ted talk no i
don't need anyone
because here's what i've learned because
i used to be like that
optimistic yeah like it's the production
companies are already around they're now
around 20 years they have the slates
they have like i started trying to like
come up with my ideas like right and
i'll start developing stuff see how much
money it costs like camera operator and
you cannot sell a show
easier said than done you know like not
fair
but you do have the connections in the
sense that you know the people that we i
don't know
i'm out here hustling
i'm just saying if i think that that
would be something you should go into
next i'm musically i'm sick of not being
rich and famous yeah we're all sick of
it i'm sick of it for you yeah it's it's
a rough basic life it's just so what's
next for you i would love to be like a
rich
podcaster podcasting because like when
the panda came like all the advertisers
pulled their money out of podcasting and
then like the only people podcasting
were like hillary clinton and biden and
obama i was like why can't they can't
compete this game's
podcasting is like popping again so i'm
out trying to talking yeah some
different
people 100 percent
it's the new medium that everyone's
getting on you know just like you know
you need it it's like you need tik tok
you need snapchat you need a podcast you
need it like if you are going to like
sell to your yeah people who do care
about
every platform everything for them but
um what's next having another child
getting my crystal business back to
where it was pre pandemic right so like
we were doing
numbers you couldn't even comprehend
before everyone thought they were going
to die for two years you know oh my god
i love to check out the website so that
kind of like
that was an emotional rollercoaster
because i put all my hills money yes
back into like inventory and you know we
have four offices and having 20
employees and then it's like boom and
then i didn't want to fire everybody so
then i kept everyone employed for so
long as we thought oh how two weeks has
stopped the curve and it's like another
two weeks and like i'm like finally you
know like this is for sure that was uh
that was really hard yeah that is hard i
mean i feel like pandemic really that
was really hard so we're going to get
that like what is it prattdaddy.com it
is probably not okay well okay so wrap
it up because i feel like i've been
keeping you from nowhere to be till like
four until i go live and sell crystals
so oh perfect
well thank you so much where can
everyone find you so
calm please just just buy crystals from
me
crystals if we're fine
we could we could do a code unwaxed
i'll talk to my boss heidi see how much
see if i can get it out to like 15
percent oh i would love that
maybe your listeners are allowed to test
it see if it works see if something pops
up i can't wait to try it you have to
run it it'll be fun thank you so much
for thank you all right pleasure and we
will see you angelini oh yeah
and see you next tuesday bye
[Music]
you